all right joe
joe oh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally philadelphia
philly and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young
yeah and how would you describe your
childhood
i never thought about it
was a lot of abuse or was it good yeah
it was all right it was all right
could have been better could have been
worse you know but
but nothing terribly traumatic no no
nothing traumatic that uh
what kind of kid were you in high school
why me what kind of kid were you in high
school
average average
yeah how far did you go to school i made
i made
i made it through you made it through
you got out yeah and where
did you do with your life after after
school
um worked in sales most of my life
you been married you have kids yeah
married one kid
and how old are you today how old are
you
me 60 60.
and how'd you end up down here on skid
row
by choice a choice yeah
what do you like about living on skid
row i didn't say i liked it i just said
by choice
okay yeah no
i'm in an area where i can get what i
want and nobody bothers me
and uh
i'm actually uh i spent most of my time
uh over in burbank and
glendale and uh
the guy that i work with in in glendale
i just have to i have to stay away from
him because it's uh
it's either him or me yeah you know what
i mean yeah and uh
so i just stay away from are drugs a
part of your life
no no drugs no
and what are the what are the pluses
about living on the street like this
lack of responsibility maybe
i never thought about it pluses or
minuses it's just it's where i'm at
and where at this moment i'm you know
relatively uh comfortable
right but you know you have no support
from your family or no
no how about getting a job okay i get i
get ssi
social security and that's not enough to
get housing
no i have it if i want it but i
i i choose to live on the street where
i'm at is
i don't bother anybody nobody bothers me
and it's sorry
dear friends do you have friends do i
have friends
you're very fortunate if you have one or
two that's true
no you've been
in l.a for how long you've been in los
angeles for how long
94. been a while yeah you've been
living homeless for how long of that two
or three years
two three years
are you how does it affect you
emotionally living on the street like
this
it doesn't bother me did i change
you're okay with it you're okay with it
for the moment
didn't you like that little pause there
you know like you had to think about
that
you have to think about it yeah yeah
what uh what do you
see in your future do you see getting
out of here or do you
can you see yourself just continuing on
the street for the rest of your life
no i'm not living on the street the rest
of my life and am i gonna stay here i'm
gonna
i'm gonna stay where it's warm okay you
know being from the east i had it with
the snow
and you know uh the last easter i was
there
in 1990 was 19 hours and never forget in
1994
got a foot of snow on easter sunday and
i sat there and i sat there and i sat
there and i said
that's it a foot of snow on easter
sunday this guy is gone
so yeah i'm from chicago i know what it
means yeah i just i just
decided i have to have to go where it's
warm for better or worse
and and you choose to not have a job and
be
living like this which is yeah i can
work if i want
right yeah i don't i don't have to i
get ssi and uh you know
it's not a lot but i don't need a lot
but the danger and the filth of living
like this doesn't get to you yeah
you're okay with it what would you say
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
actually that's a pretty easy one it's
just
don't think you're smarter than the rest
of the people because you're not
okay that's one thing and uh
it's been an experience and uh you know
it's it's
it's it's not affecting me
economically or any any any other way at
the moment so it's uh
so i don't worry about it did you did
you just run out of money at some point
and just realize that this year
i probably will run out of money at some
point you know if i do
you know you you uh you find a way
where there's a world there's a way yeah
but you describe yourself as happy or
would i describe myself as happy
fulfilled
two bad ones there no i mean do you feel
like your life has meaning is there any
anything that you're doing or have done
that you is there anything i would
change or there's always something you
would change you know that
you've done it yourself you know it's
just uh
you know you do things and you say why
did i ever do that you know
what one that's stupid how smart am i so
i know you know
just you look in the mirror every
morning you know you're shaving and you
go
just how smart are you not very
that's the first sign of intelligence
when you can admit that
do you find it frustrating to be around
so many people that are
on drugs and kind of now
the people in this in this area
are typical of people in this area and i
i
you know i know why they're here and
what they're doing
and it doesn't affect me i just i you
know i basically ignore them
have you ever played around with drugs
or alcohol or anything like that nah
never
yeah you're pretty unusual and yet you
seem mentally
100 percent their mentality around here
most people
drugs are a big deal and i
i just know and uh you know
and if i feel like having a beer i have
beer okay you know but it's not
that often but when i do i don't make
any secret about it it's not a problem
for you
bar meat it's not a problem for you oh
no no i'm not
i wouldn't consider myself an alcoholic
but uh you know
i don't have to have it you know but
it's uh
it's available and i feel like it well
you know do you would you would you say
you have a vice
do i have a vice we all have vices
that's why i'm asking
of course what would you say yours is
probably but my biggest thing is lack of
attention to detail
about lack of ambition how about what
lack of ambition
um no no would you describe yourself as
lazy
i
you know i could be whatever i want to
be okay
you see i'm where i'm at because that's
where i want to be at this moment okay i
didn't say it's good
or it's bad i just said that's where i'm
at no but you seem fully there
mentally you seem intelligent and
rational
and it would be like wow you know if i
were
in your situation i'd probably just get
me some kind of job and get a roof over
my head so i don't have to sleep out in
the street
and build from there yeah that might be
something to ponder but uh you know
just at this moment in time i it really
doesn't matter
so it's you know i'm doing what i'm
doing and that's the way it is i like it
sunny and 80.
big deal with me that's why i'm here
moved 3 000 miles to get to it man
you're here yeah i lived in philadelphia
man it was cold there i don't know if
you
you've been to the east right yeah i'm
from chicago chicago
okay well you got you had worse weather
than i did i think that's right
and uh i got chicago yesterday though
pardon me it snowed in chicago yesterday
and it's april uh i just uh
you know leave the snow to those people
they can have it
okay fine i like it sunny and 80 and uh
you know and we'll take it from there
and you're living the good life
i didn't say that
i didn't say that at all i just you know
what
depends what you call the good life
that's many things to many different
people right but you're enjoying you're
enjoying the nice weather you have no
responsibility you
you're free to do whatever you want to
do today
i can have as much responsibility as i
want if i if i choose to go that way
and uh but i spent my life being
responsible
for myself and other people mostly other
people and i got tired of it
you know it's it's a thankless world
you know that you know you're old enough
to know that and uh
you just uh hey i just reached a point
back here i said i had it i want 80 and
sunny
and i don't want any baloney goodbye
so i left in 94 never went back and i
don't care
i don't care you know one of these days
i'll kick the bucket and
be like everybody else you know they'll
put me under and that'll be it
all right joe well thank you so much for
sharing your story okay
i wish you a long and happy life
you know about a happy life but it'll be
all right are we done here we're done
okay thank you very much